- - Le contrat avec New York,
popour moi, c'est important.
D'D'avoir réussi à signer ce
cocontrat-là, ça, c'est un bon
cocoup. Mauvais coup, bien, peu-
êêtre que je me choque trop vite
ququand Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois dt
dedes faussetés. Il faudrait que
j'j'accepte qu'il continue de de
etet d'écrire des faussetés.
JeJe vous fais écouter Monsieur
LeLegault parce que lorsqu'il a
fafait son bilan on la
ququestionnait sur cette pressin
dedes partis de l'opposition por
obobtenir une enquête publique t
ilil a fait son bilan.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
- - Le contrat avec New York,
popour moi, c'est important.
D'D'avoir réussi à signer ce
cocontrat-là, ça, c'est un bon
- - Durant la session, beaucoup
dede questions suite au rapport
dede la protectrice du citoyen.
JeJe ne vous cacherai pas que
j'j'ai trouvé ça dur parce que
çaça m'a rappelé des moments
ququi ont été difficiles.
J Je me suis rappelé les...
leles nuits à me demander qu'es-
cece qu'on peut faire de plus.
DoDonc, ça fait évidemment
totoujours mal de se rappeler
totoutes les personnes qui sont
dédécédées dans la première vag.
BoBon, j'ai pris et je continue
dede prendre ma part
dede responsabilité dans
cece qui s'est passé.
- - Et l'explique Martine ensuie
ilil a déjà expliqué plusieurs
fofois qu'il aurait dû augmenter
lele salaire des préposés, mais
quque tous ceux qui disent qu'on
auaurait pu au mois de mars avor
c'c'était pas clair comme cela t
ououi la Colombie-Britannique,
mamais il a nommé Paris, Bostont
aiailleurs au monde et on était
papas tout seul dans ce bateau .
IlIl se défend d'avoir été aveué
lului son groupe de crises au
dédébut de la crise.
- - Sa défense et dire j'ai fait
totout ce que je pouvais faire.l
a a mis des mesures en place ete
trtromper à certains endroits il
nene voulait pas il disait qu'il
s's'est retourné d'abord et qu'l
a a trouvé des gens pourrait
prprêter main-forte dans les CHD
etet c'est un peu ça qu'il dit.a
mmême si cette semaine qu'à
l'l'impossible nul n'est tenu.
C'C'est un peu la perception qul
leleur de sa gestion de la
papandémie. Il se qu'il n'a pas
étété parfait mais il fait ce
ququ'il pouvait. Et ça marche
asassez bien je pense pas que ls
papartis de l'opposition vraimet
sesemaient le doute sur la façon
dodont Monsieur Legault a géré a
papandémie surtout la première
vavague.
- - Et on a vraiment l'impressin
quque lui a l'impression qu'une
fofois que le rapport de la
cocoroner déposée que les
QuQuébécois ne réclameront pas
vrvraiment une autre commission
d'd'enquête parce que ça va être
loloin. Qu'en pensez-vous?
- - Je suis convaiaincu que Monr
LeLegault pense qu'il n'aura pas
bebesoin d'en déclencher une ele
a a probablement raison. Quand l
didit qu'il a fait tout son
popossible contenu des
rerenseignements qu'il avait, la
popopulation le croit je pense e
nonon bien vu qu'il y avait des
ererreurs mais il ne donne pas u
totout de la bonne volonté de
MoMonsieur Legault. D'autre par,
paparce qu'on fait beaucoup la
cocomparaison avec ce qui s'est
prproduit à les tâches arrêtés
prpremiers ministre et qu'il
auaurait dû céder aux pressions
popour déclencher une enquête sr
lala corruption dans la
coconstruction et le lien avec s
fifinancements politiques, mais
l'l'on n'est pas du tout dans la
mmême situation. Monsieur
ChCharrest était à son troisième
mamandat il était très
imimpopulaire. Monsieur Legault
esest très populaire et ne sent
papas la pression. Vous savait
nonous courrons l'Assemblée
nanationale et nous avons
l'l'impression que le monde toue
auautour du salon bleu mais ça
n'n'accole pas tant que ça
alallasses à l'extérieur de
l'l'Assemblée nationale est de
sosorte que, l'impression génére
ququ'ils ont les CHSLD ça été ml
didigéré, bien sûr, mais de façn
gégénérale la pandémie s'est
papassée le moins mal qu'elle ne
popouvait. À ce moment-là,
MoMonsieur Legault aura pas à se
poposer très longtemps la questn
susur ce devrait faire une enque
ouou pas, il y en aura pas.
- - Il donne vraiment l'impressn
dedes persuadés que dans l'opinn
pupublique québécoise, ce désir
d'd'une enququête publique, n'et
papas présent.
- - C'est vrai que les Québécois
gegelés impression qu'il a quand
mmême fait tout ce qu'il pouvait
ququand il se retrouvait dans ue
sisituation où personne n'avaite
plplan de match, c'est frappant
paparce que les deux tiers des
QuQuébécois sont satisfaits de
mamanière globale de la gestione
lala CAQ en ce moment. C'est qud
mmême très élevé. Par contre, il
y y a seulement le tiers des
QuQuébécois qui sont satisfaitse
lala gestion de la pandémie dans
leles CHSLD. Cet aspect-là devit
unun peu une faille dans l'armu.
- - C'est déjà beaucoup c'est
ququand même le tiers.
- - C'est sûr, on voit que les
papartis de l'opposition semblet
bibien qu'il y a une faiblesse e
cece côté-là et c'est pour ça
ququ'il continue de taper sur le
clclou. En même temps, je suis
asassez d'accord avec Michel, la
CACAQ est très fermé et ne veult
papas faire une commission parce
quque selon eux ça va mettre tot
lele système de santé sur pause
pependant une longue période pae
quque ça va demander beaucoup
d'd'informations donc ne veut ps
sese lancer là-dedans. Quand mê,
jeje pense que les gens qui sont
dédécédés par milliers on leur
dodoit cela, devant la lumièreùu
ilil y a des enquêtes en ce
momoment, mais on met le
prprojecteur à gauche et à droie
mamais ça serait plus simple
d'd'ouvrir les lumières au compt
etet d'être certain qu'il ne ree
papas de sonde d'ombre.
- - Un autre extrait de Monsieur
LeLegault qui vante le bilan
écéconomique et il dit Télé-Quéc
vava bien et que le taux de
chchômage est très bas et qu'on
fafait mieux que les ontariens,t
mmême les Américains, alors on
lului a demandé son bon quiz
mamauvais coup.
- - Le contrat avec New York,
popour moi, c'est important.
D'D'avoir réussi à signer ce
cocontrat-là, ça, c'est un bon
cocoup. Mauvais coup, bien, peu-
êêtre que je me choque trop vite
ququand Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois dt
dedes faussetés. Il faudrait que
j'j'accepte qu'il continue de de
etet d'écrire des faussetés.
- - Ça c'était un désert qu'on a
bebeaucoup entendu depuis
seseptembre. Cette nouvelle
dydynamique entre QS et la CAQ.
MaMartine ça s'est imposé dans
nonotre jeu politique.
- - Il y a plusieurs raisons à
cecela. Les deux sont très peu
lalatinisés et très compris.
MoMonsieur Legault n'a rien à
peperdre à se battre avec Monsir
NaNadeau-Dubois envoie son premr
adadversaire. La CAQ est une
cocohabitation et 30 % de son
VaVader du Parti libéral et ce
sosont les des libéraux qui ne
vovoteraient jamais pour un
sosouverainiste. Il veut protégr
cece matelas et plutôt que de
dédébattre avec Mme Anglade, eta
dédérange les libéraux qu'il est
chchoisi Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois
paparce qu'ils aimeraient bien
rérécupérer ce matelas, je pense
quque c'est un des aspects qui
jujustifient pourquoi Monsieur
LeLegault cible Monsieur Duboist
jeje pense aussi que c'est une
ququestion de personnalité, u
MoMonsieur Legault il vient de a
gégénération aussi plus difficie
dede débattre avec les femmes,
MoMonsieur Charrest était commea
avavec Pauline Marois, et quand
c'c'était Manon Massé qui étaità
ilil n'aurait jamais traité de
rorock et si les PC ça ne passat
papas très bien c'était perçu
cocomme s'il attaquait une femm.
AlAlors là ils sont un peu sur a
mmême page tous les deux.
- - Il dit que Gabriel dit des
chchoses pas vraies sur les
cacaprices et que ça l'énerve. s
crcritiques viennent le cherche,
mamais avant de vous donner la
paparole je vais vous faire
écécouter l'origine de cette
nonouvelle dynamique qui est
scscriptée en partie par le buru
dudu premier ministre.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Depuis quelques jours,
lele premier ministre a succombé
àà l'un de ses pires défauts. Il
s's'est mis à faire sa meilleure
imimitation de Maurice Duplessi.
IlIl s'est autoproclamé père
dede la nation québécoise.
- - Maurice Duplessis,
ilil avait beaucoup p de défaut,
mamais il défendait sa nation.
IlIl n'était pas un "woke" comme
lele chef de Québec solidaire.
- - C'est payant politiquement
dede se faire traiter de "woke"
papar le premier ministre?
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Je pense q qu'on dérange
FrFrançois Legault parce que nos
prpriorités sont ses faiblesses.
PoPour le premier ministre
ququi se prétend proche du mond,
mamais qui envisage de donner ds
mimillions à un milliardaire por
unune demie équipe de baseball,
alalors qu'il y a des enfants qi
n'n'ont même pas de gymnase pour
leleur cours d'éducation physiqe
àà l'école. Moi, je pense
quque quand on expose
cecette contradiction-là,
FrFrançois Legault se fâche.
C'C'est la preuve qu'on pose
leles bonnes questions.
- - Ces rares Nadeau-Dubois pred
ququelques questions il est un u
dédéstabilisé mais elle est
tetellement habile devant les
jojournalistes. La question état
bobonne, ça lui donne de la mère
lele voit pas dans les sondages,
mamais ça lui donne alors que le
prpremier ministre s'intéresse
auautant à lui.
- - Oui je suis certain qu'il et
cocontent qu'il soit le principl
adadversaire. Québec solidaire t
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois c'est
l'l'antithèse du nationonalismet
coconservateurs identitaires qui
esest le fondement même du
didiscours de Monsieur Legault.
DaDans les deux corps ce sont ds
adadversaires idéologiques pour
l'l'autre. Pendant des années
c'c'était les libéraux et le PQ
paparce qu'il y avait
fofondamentalement la question
coconstitutionnelle qui était au
cocoeur du débat mais là c'est s
sosocial identité le multi compe
susurréalisme contre le Québec e
sosouche. Et dans les deux cas,
ilils enlèvent tout la maire à
leleurs adversaires de chaque
ccôté. Alors ils s'entendent trs
bibien pour se chicaner.
- - L'avez-vous trouvé habile,
dadans cette session parlementae
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois ces
atattaques et ces lignes?
- - Il a appris extrêmement
rarapidement. Mme Chassé était
sysympathique les gens était
rereconnaissant de sa sincère e,
de son souci de la justice
sosociale mais personne
n'n'imaginait qu'on première
miministre. Live d'un moyen né
cocorps entre les deux mécomptes
dedemandent si on boit comme
prpremier ministre mais le
dedeuxième ça pourrait Nadeau-
DuDubois, même si ses intentions
dede vote sont inférieures à cex
dudu Parti libéral. Il a une
pepersonnalité forte qui est trs
popolarisante mes compagnons art
papas ignorer.
- - J'aborde dans le même sens e
MoMonsieur Dubois est très habie
etet qu'il a le temps d'arriver
avavec la bonne question, on se
sosouvient juste avant que le
prpremier ministre Legault part
popour l'A86 il avait posé une
ququestion et lui avait fait
adadmettre que le troisième lien
n'n'était pas en ligne avec
l'l'objectif vers du gouverneme,
etet sa famille le premier
miministre dans une situation
plplutôt embêtante puisqu'il s'n
alallait parler d'environnement.
IlIl a vraiment un talent pour
poposer les bonnes questions et
pupuis je dirais aussi que ça ft
reressortir le côté arrogante de
lala CAQ. Les parties est
tetellement fort et tellement
pupuissant que je l'impression
ququ'il est habitué à se gouverr
sasans opposition et ils ont
ououblié que l'opposition a le
drdroit de poser des questions
lélégitime et on a le droit de e
papas d'accord avec ce que la CQ
prprétend être les valeurs
ququébécoises. On peut être woke
esest quand même Maître québécos
cece que Monsieur Legault ne
sesemblait pas vouloir admettre.
QuQuand elle a donné la définitn
dede ce mot il disait que c'état
unune personne qui nous empêchee
prprotéger la nation québécoise.
QuQuand il dit que Gabriel Nade-
DuDubois dit des mensonges cette
sesemaine on a eu un exemple
c'c'était plutôt le Monsieur
LeLegault qui était dans un flou
arartistique par rapport au bas-
baball. Elle a dit qu'il ne
memettrait pas un sou de l'arget
dedes contribuables là-dedans ms
ququand la cuisine un peu plus u
lilieu de dire que oui il était
popour des subventions accumule
popour les contribuables il a
plplutôt commencé à s'attaquer u
lalangage de Gabriel Nadeau-Dubs
enen disant que ce n'était pas
didigne d'un chef de parti.
C'C'était coloré.
- - Dans le fond, pour Monsieur
LeLegault il n'est pas dangereux
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois il sait
trtrès bien que les fondements e
QSQS, la nationalisation des
momoyens de production et
l'l'abnégation de la économie de
mamarché et les Québécois ne
seseront jamais embarqués dans t
avavenir prévisible et Monsieure
GoGoulet s'est très bien.
- - Mme Anglade est sorti de ce
dodossier Épinay mêle elle chere
dede l'aide.
- - C'est assez spectaculaire la
cecession qu'elle a passée. Ella
susubi des pressions à l'intérir
àà l'extérieur. Elle a un caucus
prpresque ingérable et elle a
réréussi à avoir suffisamment
d'd'appui pour passer à travers
soson congrès. Mais là c'est tot
unun virage qu'elle imposant son
paparti. Elle est pas loin de
QuQuébec solidaire, d'ailleurs l
lala regarde côté de l'oeil, il
s's'entrecroise. Madame Langlois
ététant seul pour 2022 mais c'et
trtrès difficile pour elle. Elle
esest confinée à l'indifférence,
MoMonsieur Legault ne la regarde
papas. En politique quand il
gégénère indifférence est assez
orordinaire.
- - Michel le PQ on l'a dit, Pal
SaSaint-Pierre Plamondon dans tt
çaça, il est pas allé, vous étiz
d'd'accord, qu'il n'est pas
lolongueur mais bref c'est pas
fafacile?
- - C'est pas facile un peu come
MmMme Anglade il a réussi à régr
popour un temps les problèmes de
leleadership au sein de son par.
IlIl y a personne qui change à
chchanger de chef.
- - C'est plus il y a des gens i
veveulent le travail.
- - Dans les deux cas ils n'ont
papas réussi la reconnexion avec
leles rats et c'est cela qui est
le p plus important. Ils ont réé
lala partie, mais le tous les dx
ilil y a personne qui s'est
rarapprochée d'un électorat
ququébécois francophone, alors e
prproblème du parti est pas régé
cecelui de chef oui mais pas cei
dudu parti.
- - Et Monsieur Legault a dit
auaujourd'hui que les sondages
vovont se resserrer dans les
prprochains mois.
MeMerci d'être venu parce que hr
onon a pas eu le temps de parler
dede tout cela bonne fin